Ми скучили за свободою слова бо її немає
насамперед країна за нею скучила колеги
це напевно головна проблема В нас є
єдиний марафон який втратив свої
рейтинги і втратив довіру в нас є
мільйон проблем Зате в нас є анонімні
telegram-канали які вам кожному
розказують фейки про те ким ви є
насправді в нас немає
медіаграмотності в нас насправді
відключені опозиційні телеканали
відключені без жодного пояснення без
жодних причин на жур не пускають в зону
бойових дій і навіть в стіни цього
парламенту В нас мільйон проблем і в нас
є комітет в якому три чи чотири людини в
якого взагалі немає повноважень тут один
виступаючий правильно казав Комітет з
питань свободи слова і совісті так от я
вам хочу сказати Ні свободи слова в
країні нема ні совісті тут нема